[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMIT CHOPRA: This
program enables
us to work with some of the
top development agencies
across the world.
These agencies are influencers
for some of the big clients.
So as I and my team work
with them to upscale them,
they see a dramatic change in
the kind of quality of the apps
that are coming out
from these agencies.
And it's exciting to really
see the ecosystem improve
because of the program
helping agencies
build better applications.
MAGGIE HOHLFELD: What excites me
about this event is celebrating
that hard work and all of
our agencies that have become
certified over the past year.
RAVI KORUKONDA: I mean, we get
to meet a lot of other agencies
across the globe and other--
find new countries that are
introduced to the agency
program.
We are able to
interact with them
and learn what cool
stuff they're doing.
RODRIGO CARRARESI: I'm really
happy to see Brazilian agencies
participating in a
program, engaging with us,
and receiving the award today.
Three of them were here.
And it was like a
dream come true.
ONYX MUELLER: Next
year, I'd really
like to see how much the
agency program has grown
and see how many other
partners that we'll
be able to discover and learn
with as we grow in that space,
as well.
CINTHIA PINEROLI GALVAO:
After being invited by Google
to the program,
Eldorado analyzes
the goals of the program
and the opportunity
to improve our knowledge in the
new technologies [INAUDIBLE]
helps to repair the
Eldorado for the future.
ROLF KLUGE: The program
is kind of quality proof
for our clients.
Especially for new clients,
it's very important
that it have kind of a
statement that [INAUDIBLE]
and works, yeah,
in a qualified way.
IBNU SINA WARDY: I
love this program
because we can get
more recognition.
Also, we can get higher
probability [INAUDIBLE]
the project are winning
for the best next deal
for our clients [INAUDIBLE].
NEY RICARDO: Well, what we
love most is the collaboration
thing.
We love to share knowledge and
gather together people, learn
new stuff, and
protect technology,
help people change their lives.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: I
really had a lot
of fun engaging with our
partners today at the mixer.
Developer agencies are a
key part of our ecosystem
engagement plans.
And I look forward
to seeing many of you
next year at our mixer.